des étals sur la place les halles
ouvertes depuis près d'un mois clamecy
n'avait plus connu l'ambiance de marché
du samedi matin
alors aujourd'hui les clients retrouvent
leurs habitudes sans avoir l'impression
de se mettre en danger fait généralement
mes courses au marché et que j'étais
tout à fait désolé que le marché soit
suspendu donc voilà je suis revenu avec
plaisir au marché c'est pas pire qu'en
grande surface
justement parce que bah ils ont mis du
fléchage et au sol pour délimiter les
aires mètres de distance
les gens font attention respecte on
n'est pas sur paris ou dans les grandes
villes pour la reprise il y a moins de
monde qu'à l'accoutumée mais cela reste
un soulagement pour les producteurs
privés d'un débouché essentiel pour nous
c'est vraiment important puis en tant
que producteur on a besoin d'écouler
notre marchandise si les supermarchés
ont
pour leur boulot mais nous aussi pour
qu'on puisse continuer de vivre voilà
les commerçants ont joué le jeu
chacun a adapté ses comportements pour
éviter les risques de propagation du
virus
l objet de porter des masques on l'a des
gants on est en train de se laver les
mains on prend des lingettes pour pour
désinfecter notre marche il notre
machine à carte
la préfecture a accordé une dérogation
cette semaine sur demande de la mairie à
charge pour les élus d'organiser le bon
déroulement du marché qu'on a varié ray
l'ensemble des accès au marché ce sera
la condition pour qu'on nous fassions de
demande de dérogation de toute façon la
semaine prochaine sachant que les
dérogations sont accordées de manière
hebdomadaire et aussi en fonction de
l'évolution de la pandémie sur le plan
local une matinée tests que tous ici
espère valider si tout se passe bien une
nouvelle demande de dérogation sera
déposée dans la semaine pour samedi
prochain
[Musique]